[Music]
spider-man has faced nearly every member
of his rogue's gallery during his
cinematic adventures but there are still
a few villains who have yet to make
their silver screen debut from killer
goblins to monstrous vampires to um
swarms of bees these are a few of those
villains
craven the hunter is by far the most
infamous spider-man villain to have
never featured in a live-action movie
otherwise known as sergey kravenov this
obsessive big game hunter first appeared
all the way back in 1964's amazing
spider-man vol 1 number 15. in this
story craven is hired by his friend
chameleon to bring down spider-man
inevitably the hunter quickly becomes
the prey and spider-man has craven both
arrested and deported this would mark
the beginning of a long and storied
criminal career for sergey kravenov who
has devoted his entire existence to
besting spider-man once and for all
considering craven is such a prominent
member of spider-man's rogues gallery
it'll come as no surprise to find the
fans have been clamoring for him to show
up on screen for many years and he's
come pretty close too in 2021 tom
holland even told collider that
spider-man no way home director john
watts originally intended for the third
mcu spidey movie to feature craven as
the main antagonist and now it seems
that craven is finally about to step
into the spotlight a solo film set
within sony's spider-man universe has
been on the cards for a while now and in
2021 deadline reported that avengers age
of ultron star aaron taylor johnson had
been cast as the notorious hunter
himself you didn't see that coming
should all go to plan craven the hunter
will land in theaters on january 13 2023
goblin villains will be very familiar to
fans of the spider-man movies willem
dafoe made comic book movie history as
norman osborne's green goblin in the
original spider-man while james franco
played harry osborn in sam raimi's
trilogy taking the mantle of new goblin
and spider-man 3. similarly dane dehaan
played a goblin-crazed harry osborn in
the amazing spider-man 2. in the comics
however there are far more goblins than
the green goblin and many more people
have taken the mantle than norman and
harry osborne perhaps the second most
well-known of these is the villain known
as the hobgoblin six people have
operated under that name over the years
but the deadliest of all is roderick
kingsley debuting as the masked villain
in 1983's amazing spider-man vol 1
number 238 kingsley is a billionaire
fashion designer who enters the criminal
underworld after acquiring and altering
norman osborne's goblin formula it's
probably fair to say that audiences are
probably over the green goblin by now
despite willem dafoe's dramatic return
in spider-man no way home nevertheless
the hobgoblin's movie debut could
provide a refreshing twist on a fan
favorite villain
otherwise known as the spot jonathan own
first appeared in 1985's peter parker
the spectacular spider-man vol 1 number
98 a scientist in the employee of
kingpin own creates a strange black
portal while attempting to recreate the
powers of the vigilante hero cloak it
soon becomes clear that own has gained
the ability to open these portals and
traverse physical space via the
so-called spot world own subsequently
names himself the spot and embarks upon
a criminal career the spot's unique
costume and strange abilities make him a
more visually arresting villain than
most suitably he's featured in a number
of stories beyond the comic book
universe including spider-man the
animated series and the 2017 spider-man
show it's possible he'll be popping up
on the silver screen sometime soon too
as according to murphy's multiverse the
spot could be a key baddie in the
upcoming animated sequel spider-man
across the spider-verse this could
literally not get any weirder since the
comic book version of own is a close
ally of kingpin who was the main
antagonist and into the spider-verse
it's easy to see how he might fit into
miles morales story and how the spot's
inter-dimensional powers could provide
an intriguing slant on the original
movie's multiversal antics
the inheritors are a team of super
villains best known for their role in
the original spider-verse story arc and
its follow-up spider-geddon each member
of this clan of totem hunting vampires
has dedicated their life to hunting down
spider people across the multiverse and
consuming their essences a number of
inheritors have battled spider-man and
his other selves but the two most
prominent are morlen and karn morlan is
arguably the deadliest and scariest
member of the inheritors having killed
and consumed a whole heap of spider
people during his so-called great hunt
karn meanwhile is living in exile during
his first appearance after he hesitated
on a mission to capture the master
weaver who controls the all-powerful web
of life and destiny karn's mother was
struck down and killed as a result karn
was exiled until he could prove his
return a task he attempts to accomplish
throughout the first spider-verse
storyline as the main antagonists of the
comic book version of spider-verse it
seemed strange that the inheritors had
nothing to do with spider-man into the
spider-verse still with two follow-ups
planned for that movie who knows what
the future has in store for these
dimension hopping ghouls
silver sable is one of those spider-man
characters who can act as an ally or an
enemy of the wall crawler depending on
what each story requires born sylvia
sablinova this highly skilled mercenary
was introduced in 1985's amazing
spider-man vol 1 number 265 in which she
leads the vigilante team of soldiers
known as the wild pack although she has
collaborated with a number of
superheroes over the years including
spider-man silver sable has still played
the role of antagonist every now and
then although sablinova has yet to star
in a spider-man movie the character was
once destined for the big screen in 2017
sony announced that production had begun
on silver and black a feature film
following the adventures of sable and
black cat another morally ambiguous
spider-man friend info sadly the project
wasn't destined to last and director
gina prince bythewood eventually
revealed that sony were considering
offering the story to disney plus having
previously decided to give each
character their own movie project a few
months later prince bythwood told looper
that she'd been preoccupied with her
work on the netflix movie the old guard
but that she was planning to re-engage
with the silver sable and black cat
project at some point still marvel fans
shouldn't expect to see sable gracing
the silver screen in the near future
the villain known as mr negative is a
more recent addition to spider-man's
rogues gallery first hitting the page in
2007's free comic book day the amazing
spider-man his true name isn't known but
the man who became mr negative was once
a chinese gangster captured by the crime
boss silvermane and forced to undergo an
experimental drug procedure this process
gave him control over the light force
and dark force two forms of extra
dimensional energy that are more
commonly wielded by mutants and magic
users the experiment also split the
gangster's mind into two forming the
martin lee persona a philanthropist who
works with the homeless as well as mr
negative himself the evil crime lord at
the head of the inner demons street gang
mr negative has played a prominent role
in spider-man's stories in recent years
but one of his most famous occurs in the
marvel's spider-man video game in which
he wages a war against kingpin and
norman osborne for control of new york
what are you doing to me
giving you a new perspective obviously
mr negative isn't exactly a stalwarts of
the live-action spider-man movies but
his homeless charity feast appears in
spider-man no way home so never say
never
despite being nowhere near as well known
as spider-man's a-list villains the
jackal is actually one of peter parker's
oldest foes in 1965 the amazing
spider-man vol 1 number 31 introduced
readers to miles warren a professor at
empire state university who develops a
desperate infatuation with the students
gwen stacy after stacy is killed by the
green goblin warren blames spider-man
for her death adopting the jackal alter
ego in order to get his revenge the
jackal's true identity was actually
something of a twist in the original
comic books his villainous persona
didn't emerge until 1974's the amazing
spider-man vol 1 number 129 with his
true identity revealed a year later in
number 148. in subsequent years the
jackal has fought spider-man on a number
of occasions but his most notable
contribution is the creation of clone
copies of spider-man such as ben reilly
who eventually became the jackal himself
as such the jackal has taken on a
starring role in some of spider-man's
most famous and infamous story lines
including the clone saga and spider
island
here's a pitch for you an australian
with a knack for hurling boomerangs dons
a goofy costume and turns to a life of
crime joining up with several
supervillain teams in the process think
you've heard this one before well this
isn't actually the origin of dc's
captain boomerang or at least it's not
just the origin of dc's captain
boomerang this is the story of frederick
myers aka boomerang dc's take on a
boomerang wielding criminal preceded
marvels by six years with the latter
hitting the scene in 1966's tales to
astonish vol 1 number 81 and it's also
probably fair to say that marvel's
boomerang is far less renowned than his
distinguished competitor myers is an
ex-professional baseball player known
for his strong pitching arm who was
drafted into the employee of the hydra
adjacent group known as the secret
empire his new task masters outfitted
him with special weapons and conferred
upon him the code name boomerang more as
a joke than anything else after the end
of the empire myers decides to become a
freelance assassin and in this role he
has joined the ranks of pretty much
every team of super villains to have
ever existed sadly considering dc's
captain boomerang has recently been
adapted into live action for both
suicide squad movies it doesn't seem
likely that marvel will be trying out
their own boomerang anytime soon
let's just get one thing clear here yes
this is absolutely a man made of bees
better known under the pseudonym swarm
fritz von meyer was a nazi scientist who
stumbled across a colony of mutant bees
after the end of world war ii von meyer
attempted and failed to control these
bees who consumed him alive and absorbed
him into their hive mind this not only
merged their consciousnesses but also
gave him the ability to control them at
will all of this is explained in
champions volume 1 number 15 a story in
which swarm takes on a team of heroes
including angel black widow ghost rider
hercules iceman and darkstar since then
however von meyer and his bothersome
bees have become a stalwart enemy of
spider-man more recently in ant-man vol
2 he has teamed up with scott lang to
take down the bug lords who are exactly
what they sound like as you might have
guessed swarm isn't exactly the most
serious comic book villain out there
indeed his latest stories have been a
lot of fun often leaning into the
character's arch silliness if ever a
future spider-man movie needed a
colorful and amusing secondary
antagonists to stir up trouble on the
side swarm would be just a horrific mass
of bees for the job
jackson wheel aka big wheel is one of
spider-man's weirdest foes first
appearing in 1978's the amazing
spider-man vol 1 number 182 wheel is a
corrupt businessman who hires the
villainous engineer known as the
tinkerer to create a massive deadly mono
wheel that will help him to defeat his
rival rocket racer their feud soon
brings the big wheel into the path of
spider-man sparking a rivalry that would
last well not very long at all wheel
actually disappears at the end of the
very next issue and is only returned a
few times mostly as a joke character he
has also dabbled in super heroics every
now and again and even his more recent
acts of mischief have been half-hearted
at best big wheel has yet to turn up in
a live-action adaptation of spider-man's
adventures which you probably knew
already because who wouldn't have
remembered andrew garfield fleeing a
huge wheel in the amazing spider-man 2.
still it's probably fair to say that
this guy needs to join the mcu asap cast
some highly prestigious a-list actor
throw him into battle against peter
parker and watch those box office
numbers soar
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]